[Applause]
jokic with five fouls
now james will shoot an open jumper he's
got it lebron james
with a stare down to that denver bench
timeout on the floor
the lakers get back-to-back buckets how
about the little step back for lebron
a little 5-0 run here for the lakers
they get the switch now murray on lebron
james a hobbled murray
trying to stay with him as best he can
lebron james
hits one for l.a for
pick-and-roll play last year in the
first year of lebron james and they've
missed six consecutive years with a
drought
james again oh he hits another one
lebron james
putting together a closing quarter
against the nuggets
that's what you do the most career 30
plus point playoff games
lebron james tonight his 116th
which is number one
he'll take a three lebron james will hit
a three
how about it lebron james
pulling out all the daggers here in the
fourth quarter
12-point laker lead lebron has the last
nine for la tell you what lebron james
he's done it in so many ways
leave it that's what he does the follow
through you think he knows what time it
is
you think he knows he can go to his
tenth final if he closes this out
look at the determination on his face 35
points just make it nine consecutive
it's winning time for him